A British exit from Europe is the last thing
that Europe now needs, both from a political
and an economic point of view.
Europe is still recovering from the great
economic recession.
It hasn't yet attained the 2008 level of output;
its economy is weak.
Britain would have to renegotiate terms not
only with Europe, but also with the rest of
the world in terms of their trade,
in terms of how their financial institutions
operate.
From a political point of view, Europe doesn't
need this either, because what we see in Europe
is we see Europe's politics fragmenting
we see a lot of populist movement, anti-European
sentiment.
A British exit would really fan that kind
of sentiment, and that could lead to a fracturing
of Europe as a union.
It could also lead to a renewed sovereign
debt crisis in Europe.
My view is that Brexit could start the European
crisis anew.
Please let us know your view in your comments,
and what other topics you'd like us to discuss
in 60 seconds on this and other issues.